the commercial real estate development
association here in southern nevada i
got together today to talk about
our new normal and what it might look
like the association says pre-pandemic
las vegas was celebrating some major
developments but
since everything was put on hold for a
year it's really hard to imagine what a
reboot is even going to look like
while we're showing progress as our
economy recovers we're still
not up to par with where we were before
lbcva president steve hill has some
insight into what could bring us back up
to speed
we are nearing capacity on weekends now
which is you know we've been running 88
90
occupancy generally prior to the
pandemic
it was 94 occupancy on the weekends
we're back up into the 80s
but during the week we're still in the
45-50 percent range
and that difference is the
attendees for meetings and conventions
so while we've had some events already
returned to the convention center halls
the brand new building here the lbcva
believes
our economy really won't fully recover
until more of those big players announce
their return